the days are kind of blending together
it feels like it's been a long time to
keep everyone's spirits up i'm actually
going to be making brunch for myself and
my roommates today using only the items
that are available in my pantry which is
hopefully sufficient so i'm going to get
all that out figure out what i can do
and get started
[Music]
effort do you want brunch
yeah okay i got you what are you ready
for food
yeah
obviously i'm gonna be making a crab
cake eggs benedict because eggs benedict
is one of my favorite foods to order at
every brunch and i don't have english
muffins and i don't have canadian bacon
but i do have canned crab so gotta make
it work does that sound good to you
in a bowl i'm going to combine minced
shallot dried parsley some garlic powder
dijon mustard and egg yolk
some mayonnaise
a little bit of lemon juice some lemon
zest get out of there and i'm going to
whisk this until combined that looks
great so now it's time to add my canned
crab i'm going to open
these guys up
drain drink one can of crab two can of
crab and now i'm just going to get this
nice and combined
that looks pretty good to me and then
finally i'm gonna add some panko bread
crumbs do you like crab cakes right
okay good probably should have checked
on that first
this was good to me i'm not gonna mix it
to death i just want it to be barely
combined here so i'm just gonna cover
this in plastic wrap let it sit in the
fridge for an hour and then we'll check
back all right so i'm a total idiot and
i forgot to add like three ingredients
you're also gonna need salt pepper and
optionally a little cayenne pepper if
you like some heat
get that combined
so now you can actually cover and chill
this for an hour i will see you shortly
my crab mixture has been chilling for
about an hour at this point i made some
bacon and onion roasted potatoes just in
the meantime so now it's time to shape
these guys up and fry them so i'm gonna
go for about four even pieces there's
one
all right so these look great to me they
look pretty evenly sized so i'm just
going to dust a little bit of flour
now that my crab cakes are nice and
evenly coated in flour i'm just going to
shake off any excess and it's time to
fry them so i have a pan here heating up
over about medium heat now i'm gonna let
this come to temperature i'm gonna add
some oil and i'm just gonna add my crab
cakes
so i'm gonna let these go for about
three to four minutes until the
underside is golden brown and then i'm
just gonna flip them and do the same
thing on the other side oh it smells
good can you smell that
what do you think
god
dang it you can't lie to me you can't
lie to the people oh wow that's ready to
flip
look at that cool so these have flipped
i'm just gonna let them go for another
three to four minutes until they have
the color that i want beautiful
so my crab cakes are done at this point
i'm actually going to set them aside and
move on to poaching my eggs
to make my poached eggs i have a pot
here filled with water over medium heat
i'm going to add a tablespoon of white
vinegar
and the white vinegar is going to help
the egg stay together as it poaches so
i'm going to take my egg i'm just going
to crack it
into a bowl
now i'm going to make a whirlpool in my
water and while that's going i'm just
going to
lower the egg into the middle and cover
so i'm going to leave that in there for
about three to five minutes and then
we're going to take the lid off and see
how we did so let's take a look on our
egg give that guy a scoop
ha ha
i think you can see that from there but
that is a beautifully poached egg so i'm
actually luring into a thing of cold
water just to stop it from cooking so
that the yolk remains nice and runny
when people cut into it so while that's
chilling out i'm going to finish up my
eggs and then move on to my final
component my hollandaise
finally i'm going to be making a super
easy hollandaise sauce i think
hollandaise used to be this really
really difficult thing to make until
people much smarter than the rest of us
figured out a better way to do it and
the trick to making easy hollandaise is
using an immersion blender so the first
thing you need is a tall glass and in
that you're going to add one egg yolk
some lemon juice tiny bit of salt and
then finally i'm going to add butter but
i'm going to do that as the immersion
blender is going and you're going to
slowly add this in
[Music]
oh yeah
how does that look
and that is how you make a super easy
hollandaise so at this point i just need
to assemble everything i'm going to
start with my crab cakes here this the
guy and then finally hollandaise
oh hell yeah oh you know what this needs
a little bit paprika so now that this is
together i'm just going to throw two
more plates together and i'll bring my
roommates in and we can try it out okay
all right wow
what did you prepare for us matthew i
have prepared a crab cake topped with a
poached egg and hollandaise so it is
crab cake eggs benedict look at the
color on it the colors
it looks fantastic you don't have
utensils you don't get utensils
you just dig in with your hands is this
brunch does that work
what else would it be
i don't know i didn't get that far ahead
that is a brunch prepared using only
what i can find in my pantry if there's
any other occasions you want us to try
out during our shelter and place time
let us know in the comments below you
guys are hungry
yes yeah i'll have a few suggestions
[Music]
you